فقدت جميع هذه العائلات البريطانيه احد
افراد اسرتها على الاقل خلال جائحه كوفي
19 تجمعوا في لندن يوم الثلاثاء بمناسبه
بدء جلسات لجنه التحقيق في اداره الحكومه
للوباء بالنسبه لرئيسه اللجنه يجب ان يكرم
هذا التحقيق اكثر من 220 الف بريطاني من
ضحايا الجائحه احد اثقل الخسائر في اوروبا
لقد وعدت مرارا وتكرارا ان اولئك الذين
عانوا من المشقه والخساره سيكونون وسيبقون
دائما اساس هذا التحقيق سيتم الاعتراف
بخسارتهم على مدى سته اسابيع سيتم
الاستماع الى عشرات الشهود من الشخصيات
السياسيه والخبراء وستكون جلسات الاستماع
مفتوحه امام الجمهور كما سيتم بثها مباشره
على موقع يوتيوب رئيسه اللجنه طلبت من
الحكومه تزويدها بالعديد من الوثائق من
ضمنها تبادل رسائل على تطبيق واتساب بين
بوريس جونسون رئيس حكومه المحافظين انذاك
وعدد من السياسيين ومسؤولين في الصحه اذ
اتهم جونسون بالتاخر جدا في الاستجابه
للوباء وعدم فرض حجر صحي على الفور